el país del yoga
el país de candy y la no-violencia
[Música]
el país donde encontrarte con tu yo
espiritual
[Música]
es el mismo país donde la extrema
derecha ha vuelto a ganar las elecciones
si creías que el ultranacionalismo es
algo único de occidente prepárate porque
al terminar este vídeo
donald trump te va a aparecer un
blandengue
[Aplausos]
[Música]
india es la mayor democracia del mundo
habéis oído bien hablamos de más de 600
millones de personas que han depositado
el voto en la urna en las últimas
elecciones eso es dos veces la población
total de eeuu sin embargo seguro que muy
pocos me sabréis decir el nombre del
primer ministro indio
[Música]
exacto da igual que la india sea la
mayor democracia del mundo da igual que
sea el segundo país más poblado del
planeta los medios de comunicación a
duras penas han dedicado un par de
párrafos a estas elecciones y por eso en
visual política teníamos que hablaros de
este personaje narendra modi el hombre
que ha salido reelegido como primer
ministro indio muchos pensaréis que con
este aspecto tan apacible siendo
vegetariano y practicante de yoga modi
es un político espiritual moderado y
amante de la paz verdad pues nada de eso
básicamente al lado de narendra modi
donald trump parecería bono el deudos
[Música]
habéis oído hablar de las vacas sagradas
pues es cierto existen y creedme si os
digo que son mucho más que una cosa
pintoresca del hinduismo el llamado carl
bildt el cinturón de las vacas es una
serie de estados indios donde la
religión tiene un peso fundamental en la
sociedad en estos estados existen los
llamados guardianes de las vacas en
teoría su papel consiste en proteger a
estos animales pero en muchos casos se
han convertido en bandas violentas que
atacan a las minorías principalmente a
los musulmanes según un informe de human
right watch en los últimos cinco años
han llegado a matar a 44 personas solo
por comer carne de vacas
en otras palabras que si nos ponemos a
buscar encontramos fanáticos en todas
las religiones también en la hindú ista
y si india es la mayor democracia del
mundo sus elecciones también son las más
largas en casi todos los países del
planeta las votaciones se hacen durante
uno o dos días verdad pues bien en la
india se celebran durante siete semanas
y os preguntaréis por qué pues porque en
cada estado se celebran en días
distintos y hablamos de 900 millones de
posibles votantes y si las elecciones
son largas la campaña electoral ha sido
un auténtico espectáculo desde la
escaramuza militar con pakistán hasta
una película de bollywood y si habéis
oído bien además de spots electorales
nuestro amigo en almendra modi ha
contado con su propio biopic
[Aplausos]
reseña de la película sobre el primer
ministro narendra modi una geografía
descarada como os podéis imaginar con
semejante campaña electoral modi ha
salido reelegido por mayoría
absolutísima básicamente su partido
tiene casi el 65% de los escaños y no
hay ningún otro partido fuerte que le
puede hacer oposición así que la
pregunta de hoy es por qué la india ha
dado más apoyo aún al partido que
representa el ultranacionalismo hindú
hay una deriva de la india hacia la
extrema derecha y qué consecuencias
puede tener esto tanto para la india
como para el resto del mundo hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
moody but magma gandhi es algo más que
el padre de la patria del estado indio
es un símbolo universal y su gran
propósito una vez conseguida la
independencia para la india era
construir un país secular donde
convivieron pacíficamente hindúes y
musulmanes si habéis oído bien aunque
india sea mayoritariamente hinduista en
este país hay una minoría musulmana y
decimos minoría por decir algo en
realidad hablamos de más de 200 millones
de personas que profesan la religión
islámica
[Música]
pues bien gandhi y modi son del mismo
estado pero aquí terminan todas las
similitudes modi nació en una familia
humilde y desde pequeño le fascinaba la
política así que dónde creéis que se
afilió pues en la asociación de
voluntarios nacionales también conocida
como la familia sang básicamente se
trata de una organización
fundamentalista hindú con un objetivo
muy claro los musulmanes son el enemigo
para que os hagáis una idea el asesino
de mahatma gandhi estaba vinculado con
esta organización pues bien la familia
sanz fue el germen de lo que luego sería
el partido político de narendra modi el
bharatiya janata party conocido por sus
siglas de jp y ya os podéis imaginar que
la ideología de este partido es de todo
menos centrista sin embargo en seguida
se convirtió en una de las formaciones
más importantes de la india y al calor
de este partido es como modi realizó su
carrera política en el año 2001 llegó a
ser ministro jefe del
dibujará y así es como comenzó su
leyenda básicamente la tendrá modi fue
capaz de combinar la retórica hinduista
del be jp con una política económica
sorprendentemente pragmática por un lado
durante estos años le llegaron a retirar
el visado para viajar a estados unidos
ya la unión europea y diréis porque pues
básicamente por permitir que los
radicales hinduistas camparon a sus
anchas hostigando a los musulmanes en
2002 llegaron a asesinar a más de 1000
musulmanes y las autoridades fueron
acusadas de facilitar a los radicales
listados de las propiedades de
ciudadanos islamistas pero por el otro
lado moody tuvo sus luces en la economía
privatizó varias empresas públicas creó
parques industriales y redujo un montón
de trabas burocráticas en pocos años
garat estaba creciendo a ritmos del 10
por ciento interanual todo el mundo veía
moody como un ejemplo de gestor
responsable y eficiente
[Música]
el siguiente paso
pues como os podéis imaginar con
semejante currículum el siguiente paso
era gobernar todo el país así que en el
año 2014 modi se convirtió en el primer
ministro indio
[Música]
su programa incluía acabar con la
burocracia extrema de la india
modernizar el país y mejorar las
relaciones con eeuu pensar que antes de
moody la india estaba en la lista negra
del 'tío sam' porque habían desarrollado
armamento nuclear a sus espaldas modi
mejoró estas relaciones de repente todo
el mundo estaba encantado con el nuevo
gobierno indio incluido el por entonces
presidente de eeuu barack obama que no
me creéis pues mirad mirad
[Música]
obama escribe el perfil de modi para la
lista de personalidades más influyentes
de la revista 'time' habéis oído bien
barack obama llegó a ser amigo personal
de narendra modi pese a que no podían
partir de ideologías más distintas y
diréis cómo es esto posible pues
básicamente porque todo el mundo estaba
esperando el despegue definitivo del
gigante indio y modi parecía el hombre
adecuado vale era un poco
fundamentalista tal vez no sea el mayor
fan de los derechos humanos pero en fin
cosas peores se han visto y la pregunta
es qué ha hecho modi en su primer
mandato pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
i
el trump hindú el asesino de gandhi fue
un patriota para esperar un momento
porque la frase no es mía estáis de
acuerdo y que ensalzar el asesinato del
héroe nacional no parece la mejor idea
para una campaña electoral verdad pues
esto es lo que decía praia thakur antes
de las elecciones raya thakur es una
política del bj penn y si ha ganado las
elecciones en su distrito al igual que
móvil y sin ninguna de estas cosas os
parece lo suficientemente brutal mirad
lo que dice a mí
que es nada menos que el presidente del
partido de nar entramos
y jura que arrojará a los inmigrantes
ilegales al golfo de bengala os dije que
al terminar este vídeo donald trump os
iba a parecer un hippie pacifista y os
preguntaréis cómo es posible que
narendra modi y su partido siendo tan
radicales arrasen en la india de esta
manera pues una palabra economía en este
sentido moody se parece bastante a
erdogán el presidente turco los dos son
extremistas religiosos los dos han
tenido muy buenas relaciones con eeuu y
los dos han presumido de buena gestión
económica ya decís que no conocéis la
historia de erdogán pues os la contamos
en este vídeo y si queréis descubrir lo
que ocurre en todo el mundo incluidas
aquellas partes que nos salen en los
medios de comunicación tradicionales no
olvidéis suscribiros a visual político y
darle a la campanita para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones
recordad que la campanita es muy
importante porque si no la pincháis no
os llegarán las notificaciones al
teléfono móvil pero sigamos con nuestra
historia durante el gobierno de narendra
modi la economía india ha seguido
creciendo a un ritmo del 7 por ciento
interanual
su administración ha conseguido sanear
las
creando impuestos indirectos parecidos
al iva y moody se ha labrado una imagen
de hombre humilde trabajador y a la vez
hábil para los negocios
[Música]
pero como decíamos antes el peso de los
radicales en su gobierno ha sido muy
importante y básicamente les ha abierto
la puerta de todas las instituciones del
gobierno actualmente la familia sanz
domina a la policía el ejército y la
justicia pero sus tentáculos van mucho
más allá controlan la escuela privada
más grande del país
eso significa que 5 millones de niñas
están bajo su influencia y también
tienen fuertes vínculos con otra
organización fundamentalista que
protagoniza noticias como estas
[Música]
los activistas de baja randall golpean a
un niño musulmán por ir de compras con
una niña hindú así que como podéis ver
el avance del fundamentalismo hindú en
la india está alcanzando cotas muy pero
que muy preocupantes y digo
fundamentalismo hindú porque la
ideología de modding va mucho más allá
del nacionalismo pulí duro por ejemplo
su gobierno no ha perdido ni un segundo
en ofrecer la nacionalidad india a los
inmigrantes ilegales que proceden de
países musulmanes como por ejemplo
afganistán bangladesh o incluso el
archienemigo de la india pakistán
siempre y cuando cumplan un requisito no
ser musulmanes es decir que el
radicalismo del viejo tape no es sólo
nacionalista sino también religioso sólo
quieren que queden las religiones
propias de la zona como el hinduismo el
budismo el jainismo y el sijismo el
problema pues que en la india siguen
teniendo 200 millones de musulmanes
suponen el 14 por ciento de la población
y creedme su vida no es fácil y diréis
pero como les oprimen exactamente pues
volvamos al ejemplo de las vacas
antes de morir las vacas eran animales
sagrados mientras se mantenían
productivas ahora bien cuando un
merecían y dejaban de ser rentables las
autoridades hacían la vista gorda y
permitían que acabaran en los mataderos
que normalmente son negocios en manos de
la población musulmana gracias a esto la
carne de res terminaba siendo alimento
para esta minoría religiosa pues bien
con la llegada al poder del ve jp en
muchos estados se está prohibiendo el
consumo de carne de vaca es más el
gobierno de móvil ha gastado casi 90
millones de dólares en construir las
llamadas 2 a las que son albergues
religiosos para vargas
en estos albergues se cuidan las vacas
son los principios del hinduismo y se
promueve el vegetarianismo por supuesto
todas estas medidas son un ataque
frontal a la comunidad musulmana que en
muchos casos vivían de criar las vacas
para consumo humano sin embargo para
muchos fanáticos esto todavía no es
suficiente los radicales hinduistas
todavía quieren más por eso en la india
ocurren cosas como esta
un informe concluye que los vigilantes
de vacas en la india mataron al menos a
44 personas aproximadamente 280 personas
heridas en más de 100 ataques durante
tres años ya os lo decíamos antes se
puede ser fanático en muchas religiones
incluida la hinduista y ya sé lo que
estaréis pensando alguno bueno y qué
pasa con la economía qué pasa con esa
imagen de gestor que tenía narendra modi
pues en este sentido las cosas también
dejan bastante que desear ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
[Música]
cortinas de humo el 30 de enero es el
día de la paz en honor de gandhi porque
ese día es cuando fue asesinado a estas
alturas ya os habréis dado cuenta de que
cualquier paralelismo entre gandhi y
moody es pura coincidencia gigante era
un símbolo del activismo pacifista modi
es un auténtico bioma no si es cierto la
india sigue creciendo pero eso no es
mérito de modi en realidad la india
lleva creciendo desde hace décadas pero
también crece la población y lo que no
crece tanto es el empleo sobre todo
entre la gente joven
el paro juvenil en la india está en
máximos históricos y su promesa de crear
10 millones de trabajos se ha quedado en
agua de borrajas y tampoco están de buen
humor los agricultores el gobierno de
modi aumento las importaciones de
productos agrícolas y redujo las
exportaciones para bajar los precios
esta medida ha sido muy buena para las
grandes ciudades pero los agricultores
se han visto afectados ahora bien sin
duda alguna el gran fracaso económico de
moody ha sido su lucha contra el dinero
negro
de la noche a la mañana el gobierno
retiró de la circulación el 80 por
ciento de los billetes la idea era
obligar a todo el mundo a usar tarjetas
de crédito y transferencias bancarias de
esta forma no podían evadir impuestos
el problema pues que en la india- no
todo el mundo tiene una cuenta bancaria
así que de repente la gente se agolpaba
en las sucursales de los bancos la mayor
parte de las entidades no sabían muy
bien cómo reaccionar y quiénes fueron
los más afectados pues obviamente las
clases bajas que tienen negocios
modestos en los que normalmente se paga
en efectivo una frutería una barbería
cualquier comercio de calle que podáis
imaginar
[Música]
pero esto significa que moody podía
perder la mayoría absoluta o al menos
eso es lo que pronosticaban muchas de
las encuestas
en cualquier caso estaba claro que iba a
ganar las elecciones pero al menos a
principios del año 2016 parecía evidente
que tendría que pactar con otros
partidos así que qué hace un político
fundamentalista cuando su estrategia
económica no funciona del todo bien pues
algo muy parecido a lo que ha pasado con
el foro
india frena el poder de amazon y walmart
para vender productos en línea pero ya
os hemos indicado que si en algo es
experto un pirómano como moody es en
crear cortinas de humo y para ello nada
mejor que avivar aún más el orgullo de
ser hindú como os hemos explicado
recientemente en este otro vídeo la
india de modi ha realizado su primer
ataque aéreo sobre pakistán desde hace
más de 40 años como respuesta al
atentado de cachemira por fortuna por el
planeta el conflicto no ha ido más allá
y no ha desencadenado una guerra entre
dos potencias nucleares pero a moody me
ha venido de perlas
[Música]
en enero de 2019 las encuestas decían
que perdería la mayoría absoluta y ahora
cinco meses después y con un conflicto
con pakistán de por medio
moody ha arrasado en las elecciones
repito su coalición roza el 65% del
parlamento así que ahora la pregunta es
para vosotros creéis que modi está
jugando con fuego con su estrategia
nacionalista conseguirán su objetivo los
más radicales de reemplazar a gandhi por
moody como el gran héroe nacional y lo
más importante de verdad pueden modi
sacar a india de la pobreza
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribimos a visual
político y darle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]